i haven't talked about this publicly you
know to any great extent but along the
way i hit numerous roadblocks again and
again sometimes they were situational
like people close to me dying and the
grief that came with that sometimes it
was my own kind of um feeling like i was
getting pulled back toward a state of
mind that wasn't healthy for me
and so on but i think what i've
been good at
at least good at not great at but at
least good at is
finding
really good mentors that would allow me
to get to the next
node of the next milestone
and i should say that some of those
mentors were real people
that i i didn't say can you be my mentor
not that that would be a bad thing but
really tried to model my behavior after
people that i respected
and sometimes those mentors were people
that
i didn't know at all i mean i'll just
say this right now i mean i'm gonna
embarrass him by saying it but you know
i was a junior professor meaning before
i got tenure running a lab
i had a bulldog puppy a laboratory and a
home for the first time in my life and
feeling very very overwhelmed and
distraught and i made
many of the things that i heard
tim ferriss say
sort of central to my way of doing
things i didn't go four hours of work a
week but i did start to get extreme
about organizing my schedule so he was a
big influence on you tim huge huge and
and i know tim a little bit we have some
common friends and i feel very fortunate
that now we're in touch because gone on
his podcast and gotten to know one
another but just huge i mean like there
were no organizational forces in my life
for me at that time that could help me
navigate through this landscape of you
know i'd never been a professor before i
had
taught it now it was many years ago now
but
i knew how to do science i felt
confident in my ability to take an empty
room and a budget and create buy the
right equipment and do the experiments
hire the people i had no problem with
that
but how to
regulate my time and my energy and how
to um
communicate with people i mean he had
these like little things that i don't
like the word hacks i hate it because
hacks are
implies that you're using something for
a purpose that it wasn't intended for
that's a hack but he had things like
instead of asking people um
you know like what's up when they come
in your office asking them you know what
specifically you know what what can i do
for you like what do you need right
really cutting to the chase because time
became a valuable resource little things
like that tiny things on the fit on the
surface that translate into huge
conversion in terms of time and energy
um
and even just setting aside some savings
and things i it's not that i'm not dumb
about money but i wasn't i've never
really taken the time to think about how
i was gonna invest money or do anything
so tim did a tremendous service for for
me uh without realizing it and i've
thanked him now a million times i'm
gonna thank him a million times i'm
thinking thank you tim i'm thanking you
again things like that so selecting
mentors then eventually when it came
time to start podcasting i mean lex
whether or not he knows or not you know
just thinking oh here's another guy
who's a he's a scientist he's mit the
fact he always wore that suit and i'm
gonna copy them and just always wear the
same thing because i don't have to take
guesswork i can take the guesswork out
of it there were little things that
were super deliberate that just saved me
time and energy and i think that
that's helped me along the way and then
the other thing is i have really tried
to adopt this idea that
when it's inevitable
and it will inevitably arrive that
stress grows us
that it really sharpens decision making
it really sharpens decision making and
you know if you have a very stressful
event and then you recover from it the
worst thing to do is just go and keep
going you need to take some time and
reflect about what led into that so i've
i think i'm very good at leveraging fear
into positive change if i really think
about most of the major shifts in my
life it was
i'm scared as hell to remain in this
situation and i'm very good at
broadcasting fear into my future uh you
know if i've ever been in a
bad relationship it was
clearly if i stayed in it couldn't have
been so bad that i felt like i had to
leave so i would broadcast and project
you know how horrible it would be for my
future children and i might even
build that up a little bit my system now
one could say well maybe you could have
navigated successfully i'm better at
projecting fear into my future and that
has led me to make i think better and
better decisions over time what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace